look at how good this animation is this
is
all cgi every square inch of them every
feature of their anatomy is used as a
weapon of some sort
dude that explosion was so fast it was
just like flame
for like 10 frames and that was it did
you think that horse stunt was real or
was that like a cg horse i
know the answer to that whole bunch of
details about that horse stunt
thanks to hbo max for sponsoring this
video
hey what's up everyone welcome back to
another episode of visual effects
artists react we are joined by alex
laurent here today he is a visual
effects art director and so he's going
to have some pretty cool insights on
some of the decision making that goes
into the visuals
that you see on your screen i am super
excited for this episode because hbo max
approached us and asked us to do a
reactions in this series on their
streaming platform the shows
on hbo max they have the best visual
effects for series period in the in the
history of entertainment there's a
couple huge standouts that just come to
mind you know game of thrones chernobyl
watchmen the list goes on i mean i'm a
big
fan of watchmen and my favorite thing
from watchmen is the mirror dude and
we already looked at that check it out
i'm a huge watchman fan as well
i like the visual design of westworld a
lot the effects so many beautiful
moments there
and you just keep on going down the list
well we're gonna be looking at a few
things today
it's gonna be a great episode nico what
are we looking at first in my opinion
the best battle scene to ever have been
put on film is the battle of the
bastards wow that is quite a statement
but you know hey in my humble opinion
right
let's take a look and we'll see yes
oh it's been a long time since i've
watched this they managed to nail the
feeling that oh he's actually going to
make it out of this
yeah and then you know
right through the heart yeah what a way
to start a fight
dude what a shot there though just like
the hooves going the best way to set up
production
value and quality in your visual effects
is when you have it in your
cinematography
and in your costumes the production
quality goes throughout you're not
relying on the visual effects
to elevate all the other craft that is
an hbo quality
solid horse stunt did you think that
horse stunt was real or was that like a
cg horse i
know the answer to that i actually know
a whole bunch of details about that
horse stunt so this shot's actually
really interesting they have a rope and
they're just pulling the head of the
horse to get it to do the effect of the
stunt man taking the hit
and they just are putting jon snow's
actual face onto the stunt man and down
it goes
when i see that they did really
interestingly there though is they
didn't just take an image or a 3d model
of his head they shot him practically
rotating the correct amount and he's
just wearing like a t-shirt
yeah because they don't need anything
they're literally just going to grab
this part here
and they got just enough of the rotation
to cover them
and we're into the chaos man so crazy
yeah it looks so good
dude that's just so many horses going
down this winter is so well done oh this
is a winner yeah that's right
the cinematography and the editorial
style of this whole scene
is also helping a lot and it's not by
accident there's this documentary
i'm in the middle of it and that lends
realism to the whole thing you don't get
this
super slick polished quote-unquote
hollywood look that sometimes can make
things feel less realistic it's
interesting to point out because that's
actually something the director
specifically said he was trying to do in
this episode that's why they keep the
camera with jon snow because a battle
can be very
overwhelming in how you convey the
brutality of it it's like let's just
stay with one man
yeah so what do you guys think is vfx in
the shot okay i think all the arrows are
vfx
or most of the arrows are vfx i'm
willing to bet
some of the horses are not actually
there i would agree
they are one of the things that's
hardest to control in terms of perfect
choreography
and if there's one thing that stands out
about this whole shot is the accidental
perfection
a horse running through frame someone
falling and that is very hard stuff to
choreograph
the question though is which horses are
cg because i can't
tell the difference the only real things
in this shot is jon snow and that one
soldier to his left and the ground dang
so there's
just like there's dudes dying in there
just not there those are perfect
cg humans they knew their strengths they
could have a person look pretty
realistic when all you see is their
armor so let me hit you one more time
right here what is real and what is
faking okay so now i feel like you're
gonna you're gonna try to trick me so my
first instinct was to say
none of this is real but now i've come
around to be like
is it all real well you know he wants
you to think that right
i mean i'm looking at that dude's face
on the right there and it's like that's
a pretty realistic looking face
the whole body could be pretty much a
stunt guy but i'm also looking at blood
splatter which obviously can't possibly
there's a
there's a stake sticking out of that
horse that is
obviously not a real horse i love how
you guys go down these
rabbit holes okay nico what is it all
right
this dude and that horse and the right
are all 100 fake
they are completely computer generated
and the dude and the horse on the left
is 100
real i think you'll be surprised to
discover just how much this scene is cgi
there are some real things but the vast
majority of it is actually not real and
it's just a testament to some of the
flawless visual effects that are in this
episode
look at how good this animation is this
is all cgi
there's like two horses in the shot for
real you know that's just
beautiful painstaking keyframe animation
talk about observing reality those
animators need to observe horses
up close and personal the thing that
betrays cgi
in like 99 of the cases is the animation
right that's right
and you're getting to a situation here
you can't do motion capture but in this
case
it's all hand animation and to get the
hand animation
that dialed in is just pure artistry and
dedication and talent
one of the things that is really really
helping them here is they have a bunch
of physics simulations happening
around the animation so the horse's hair
is a physics simulation the bridle the
cloth hanging off the back of the guy's
armor
all that dirt and mud they did a
procedural houdini
system so as the animated horse's hooves
hit the ground they would do dirt
ejected from the ground actually like a
consequence even if you don't notice it
consciously
that's the kind of thing that registers
as naturalistic yeah it's one of those
things that you would notice if it
wasn't there 100
and the lighting's not an easy lighting
environment to replicate either the soft
ambient lighting getting that to look
good is very difficult but they matched
it perfectly
they are indistinguishable from the real
horses and soldiers around them also
shout out to the unsung heroes
the mash movers and rotoscopers on the
shot you guys match move the heck out of
it in rotoscopes okay we managed to
rotoscope
blurry swords and all that kind of stuff
like look at his rotoscope on his arm
right there this cgi is
in my opinion some of the most flawless
cgi i've ever seen
and of course when we say cgi we're not
talking about just a photo realistically
rendered thing
it is all of these elements brought
together it's the compositing the paint
and roto work
the match moving and the tracking if any
of those things fails
it drops the whole thing it's like
everybody needs to come bring their a
game
so you see us critique vfx all the time
but how about we put our money where our
mouth is and do a little vfx challenge
well tomorrow
we are going to try to follow a bob ross
tutorial but we have to do it in real
time and we have to do it in 3d
on the computer so keep your eyes on
this channel tomorrow for that video to
see if we are
able to maintain that bob ross chill
factor while under pressure
i'm glad you could join me today you
ready to do a fantastic little painting
the reason i'm back home my father
just gone missing so lovecraft country
is a fantastic show i'm really
enjoying it and there's some incredible
vfx work here especially when they start
like
changing bodies and shedding their skin
it's really
gory but also very realistic looking
this show also has a lot of
creature work and they have like cthulhu
oh yeah and cthulhu in here
the shogoths they have the shogus
i didn't know this this show was this
like absurd it's film quality stuff
the effort and the detail they put in my
own perspective from the design and
concept stage
those show goths went through a
fantastic process and they are
incredibly original designs and it was
just really beautifully executed when
you're doing design for a creature
do you have to worry about the
plausibility of its physicality very
much
oh absolutely that's where we're walking
the line of believability is in the
design
that's the skill of it and the art of it
is pushing the extremes but always
grounding it in some sort of anatomical
reality every square inch of them every
feature of their anatomy is used as a
weapon of some sort
is useful it has a practical purpose the
tail has this blade that they use to
pierce
those little arms under there have
spikes that they used to gut and
it's all gross awesome covered with eyes
yeah the dozens of eyes on its
back and they went to great lengths to
design those eyes so that they would
read really well
a lot of attention to detail in this
creature design and the teeth the mouth
alone it's just like
this massive shark mouth on steroids
these
rows and rows of teeth
it's an actual model prop they built in
the shape of his head
and so he's actually resting his hand on
that so it gives the actors a reference
for where to look at
it gives him an actual physical thing to
put his hand
against and because it's white they're
able to extract the shadows from it
to really get like that ambient
occlusion and shadow from it even though
they're replacing some of the shadow
there below but like
the contact content is there
so this woman hippolyta basically fell
into like this weird inner dimension and
ended up in the future and now she's in
like this white room
and then this character comes into the
room
wow look at that hair that is some
serious hair
so apparently what they did was the
makeup artist actually specifically had
to buy the biggest afro wig he could
find and he cut it into shape so that
that shape is very intentional but it
all
ended up being replaced in cg basically
they already had a really big afro but
they wanted a bigger afro
and that shot it's such a needless thing
to do
yeah it is completely unnecessary
because it's only for the vfx breakdown
and that is my favorite thing about vfx
breakdowns
what we're seeing is the hair is not
actually growing from her head
it's growing from this shape with this
floppy soft body
physics but it's also important to note
that the hair is still being
used specifically around her face
because that hair interaction with her
face we're talking the shadows
the lighting the actual hairs that are
kind of sticking out that is still
coming through from the real plate it's
everything kind of surrounding that that
is then replaced
and it also serves as excellent
reference they know exactly what it
should look like in that lighting
so one last thing from lovecraft country
i wanted to take a look at the
mansion that they're in collapse oh yes
this shot here though pretty sweet i
mean yeah man yeah that smoke though
is it just a little too perfectly wispy
it was like i could tell the the
resolution of the
the sim really you can see like
pixelated chatter in there
well it's not so much pixelation as much
as just like overly smoothing
like not enough resolution and other
times where it's like some of the
wispiness
is too directional it's tricky because
we're talking about voxels volumetric
pixels they're basically cubes right
one cube's affecting another cube
affecting the other cube so it's
propagating from cube to cube to cube
which causes the propagation to kind of
follow
the directions of cubes when you stack
cubes together you know it's left right
forwards backwards upside down
cubes aren't diagonally going out right
and so
as the smoke is moving through a lower
red simulation is you can see those
steps in those cubes but it doesn't
transfer diagonally as smooth as it say
transfers from side to side
you can kind of see the corners and the
way the fire kind of ends up making
these little right angles and corners
oh i'm looking for them everywhere look
right there look at that wisp oh you see
what i'm looking at it almost looks like
a rib cage
yep you can see there's all the
individual voxels right there
effectively pixelization
voxelization yeah the studio is probably
incredibly aware of these drawbacks but
they're also just like we have no choice
we have to get the shot out
we have to collapse an entire mansion
it's like the fire is fine and you know
what if i was doing this shot my fire
would probably look even worse because
i'd be like it's good
effects supervisors and effects art
directors and effects artists everywhere
have to make hard choices you're up
against that deadline and you've got to
make some hard choices and the things
that matter most
are the things you focus on and that is
not where our eye is right there our eye
is on the character running towards us
yeah
guys we are so close
to 5 million subscribers get your
friends hide your kids
and wife to subscribe
what hide your kids and your wife
guys we are so close to 5 million
subscribers please subscribe to get us
to this milestone and be so cool
all right let's go a little darker now
let's take a look at chernobyl which in
my opinion is one of the best
mini series i've ever seen chernobyl is
a prime example of invisible effects
that set the stage
and just some really cool phenomenon
effects
i was going to say oh like radiation
poisoning but then he said
cool and i was like oh no sorry cool is
maybe not the right word
chenko looks down on the enormous steel
lid of the reactor
and sees the impossible obviously we
know about
chernobyl from history and this is a
dramatic recreation of the events
at long last we have arrived 123.45
explosion dude that explosion was so
fast it was just like flame
for like 10 frames and that was it which
honestly is kind of how explosions work
you never really see an explosion nicely
expand it's always just like here one
frame and the next frame it's all the
way out here it's like watching glass
break in slow-mo it's too fast
really interesting approach to this
explosion here too so it's a nuclear
reactor meltdown
no one's ever seen the nuclear fuel on
fire we've seen the smoke
you know there's pictures of that stuff
but no one's looked at the fuel that's
actually on fire
anybody that has is dead that means
you're getting a direct blast of
radiation
at such an intensity that you literally
will probably die before the day is over
dneg did a bunch of effects work on the
show and they did a bunch of research to
try to be accurate to the physics of the
situation so like in real explosion you
basically like in the special effects
world of hollywood you use a black
powder charge it kicks up a bunch of
gasoline into the air and the base of
the embers that burning black powder
ignite the gasoline which has been
vaporized or atomized and you get a big
fireball in this case
the fuel of the fire is the melted down
radioactive material it's a fuel that
doesn't just go into the air and burn
it's a fuel that stays in the ground and
continues to burn
constantly it'd be very hard and
difficult and expensive to do that in
special effects
it's a situation where you can use the
most modern of physics simulations fluid
dynamics
to simulate and emulate this explosion
and continue with the motion that this
explosion would have that you can't get
through special effects so it's a really
interesting use of capturing a natural
phenomena you might be wondering
wow it's crazy they had to rebuild an
entire power plant there's actually a
twin of the chernobyl power plant in
lithuania and it was built at the exact
same time
very similar blueprint it's actually the
same type of reactor it's an rbmk
reactor
they're able to film there and have it
look like chernobyl there's in fact
there's wide
shots where all they did was like add in
a couple extra things in the background
but it's like the exact same building
the exact same power line structure
that kind of thoroughness and respect
for historical accuracy
is really commendable and all the more
so because it's something that i don't
think they quote unquote had to do
they could have faked in something that
was a plausible equivalent it wouldn't
have diminished the story but they
wanted that extra level of accuracy
so the thing about that power plant
though is that the city it's in is a lot
bigger than pripyat usually you're
adding in buildings and cool things like
that when doing visual effects in this
case
they're adding in forests and removing
buildings that's the contrast
they removed that one building off in
the distance and it's like
99.9 of people watching this would have
never
noticed that those buildings in the
background shouldn't have been there
they kept the sky
they liked the sky they did as a vfx art
director you're usually tasked with
creating the style and the
visual sort of aesthetic of a movie and
here all of the reference that normally
a concept artist would be creating they
just have photographs
yeah and i bet they had troves and
tropes of fantastic photography and
reference but it still comes down to
making a dramatic
composition that works well within the
story and conveys the story
points and the mood that the director
wants the thing that i
question or i think about as a filmmaker
is is this something where you are
paying respect to what happened
it's a form of entertainment but it's
also a form of like tribute tribute
and reflection on what happened then
where's the line yeah where's the line
it's a tough one and there's no clean
answer to it when we are dealing with
recreating something terrible that truly
did happen
it absolutely demands respect from
everybody but the line between
representation and exploitation is
something we always have to be mindful
of and i think this is a great example
of recreating an event respectfully i
think this speaks to
the human need to put narrative to
things it's just how we approach the
world but real life doesn't have a
narrative
things just happen they don't follow the
plot line of a movie things aren't
always motivated
what i always respect though is when a
show like chernobyl attempts to put a
narrative
onto history having that restraint or
that understanding of letting
history be messy i always really
appreciate that and i feel like that's
something that ends up making
something a classic rather than just a
momentary piece of entertainment
chernobyl the show
is special in how much effort they put
into historically recreating the event
it gets just close enough where you can
feel some of that history yeah
yeah and that's that's wonderful thanks
again to hbo max for sponsoring this
video it was very easy to be able to
just look at only their content and make
an entire episode about it that was a
joy to do
there's a bunch of amazing series on hbo
max if you guys have not
watched any of them definitely go check
them out they actually have a new
more affordable subscription option it
does have ads but they
are minimal ads for 9.99 a month and
then there's a regular subscription for
a month go check it out there's a link
in the description below you probably
can't find any other series
out there that have as much dedication
to things like the quality visual
effects you see in hbo max
that goes through the casting and the
directing talent and the writing talent
they hire
the production value is consistent
throughout the visual effects rise to
that bar
every time if we're to do another hbo
max episode we need to look at some more
stuff so if you have any sort of hbo
originals that you'd like us to take a
look at leave a comment down below and
we'll check it out thanks so much for
watching everyone
we'll be here next week alex thanks for
being on the show with us today thank
you so much
my pleasure it's been so fun